at least six Palestinians have been
killed in an Israeli Army raid and
occupied West Bank Israeli forces have
stormed a refugee camp in Janine the
fighting broke out between Israeli
soldiers and Palestinian gunmen after
our house was besieged we're going to go
live to Sarah khilad this following
developments forest from Ramallah the
numbers are starting to increase
confirmed at least six Palestinians have
been killed they're mostly in their 20s
but one who's a 49 year old that they on
the Israeli media is reporting that is
linked to an attack that was carried out
against Israeli settlers just over a
week ago we've also had a rise in the
number of those injured now it's
starting to at least 15 wounded two of
them are critically injured and we are
likely to see that number to rise it was
a big Israeli raid there now retreating
from Janine refugee camp there are
helicopters hovering Israeli helicopters
after a drone of theirs was downed by
Palestinians in Janine refugee camp that
was happening as another raid was
carried out south of nablis at another
refugee camp where they detained two
young men of those two men are said to
be the sons of the 49 year old that was
a killed in Janine refugee camp all of
it said to be linked to this attack that
happened uh last Sunday in Hawaii where
a Palestinian shot and killed two
Israeli settlers that were cutting
through to go to an illegal Israeli
settlement where they were heading and
now this area is an area of tension
Janine Camp itself is also a place where
10 Palestinians were killed just in
January in a big Israeli race so we're
seeing a rise in these roads uh Israeli
forces raiding Janine as well as other
areas in occupied West Bank with the
largest number of deaths just this year
in the beginning of this year we're
looking at more than 65 Palestinians
killed
Sarah you and the teams there have been
reporting on an increasing number of
attacks on both sides over the last
several weeks or so is there a sense
that there is a significant escalation
well it's worth that's that is the case
with raids with demolitions uh with even
settler Israeli settler attacks
averaging at three every single day just
this year alone the UN says this is the
highest number in more than a decade
it's also the highest number in more
than a decade for the beginning of a
year to see that many demolitions we're
at more than 2 000 people that have been
wounded in just the first two months of
this year alone this is a time where the
international con Community has
condemned these uh this rise in numbers
of deaths it's also condemned the new
Israeli government at wanting to expand
its settlements here in occupied West
Bank now it's worth noting that the um
one of the people that was killed in
this Gene refugee camp was a member of
the Palestinian Authority security now
we're looking at people that are
increasingly becoming armed within uh
the Palestinian community in occupied
West Bank as well as occupied East
Jerusalem we're looking at Lone Wolf
attacks that have been carried out
against Israelis since the beginning of
the year at a time when the Israeli
government is most right-wing government
that has settler members that are
ministers that are being accused of
provoking uh such uh sentiment
especially amongst Israeli settlers when
it comes to Palestinians in the occupied
West Bank there was also a meeting that
was held recently in Jordan with a
meeting that was initiated by the US by
the United States with the Jordanian and
Egyptians and Israeli as well as
Palestinian Authority Authority members
present to de-escalate those tensions we
have had a reaction just coming in the
last uh 20 minutes from the PLO saying
the occupation government has a clear
decision to open a war against the
Palestinian people it says that it's
continuing its Massacre's settlements
demolition of homes and burning Villages
now that's the same rhetoric that it
often says whenever these raids are
carried out but the situation on the
ground now has been extremely tense and
just earlier today my colleague Knitter
was in Hawaii speaking to people that
had been attacked overnight by Israeli
settlers a family while Israeli soldiers
were watching so this is another thing
that's been brought up also by the
International Community saying that is
the Israeli government this new Israeli
government needs to ensure that uh
soldiers or those that are standing and
watching that this has to come to an end
thank you very much indeed